What immediately struck me was the fact...
...that there were less machines and more humans.
I suppose that's the feeling that you get…
...when you're wearing a Chanel garment.
It's beautiful, but there's an extra touch to it,...
...and I suppose it's the human touch.
Amazing.
You know, it takes a team to build a dream.
You know, people work hand in hand,...
...and they're all focused on one common goal,...
...whatever that particular North Star is.
Here, I would say it's effortless excellence.
It's like a guild that's filled of just artists...
...who take time and skill set, precision,...
...passion, connection among others,...
...to make something as simple as this.
It's not simple, but it looks effortless is the point,...
...and that takes a tremendous amount of talent...
...and hours and hours and hours of practice.
In my world, it's the same thing.
It's just a different skill set.
It's beautiful.
You know, the collection of these maisons...
...sort of complete the kingdom of Chanel,...
...and I think that just makes them unique,...
…because they understood the importance of preservation of the skill.
I think that's what makes Chanel the kingdom that it is.
There's something very beautiful about preserving the arts.
You know, it's the secrets of the methods and processes...
...that get lost as time goes on,...
...and I think Chanel is very wise to preserve this place and teach.
You know, so people could come and learn the craft.
It's a beautiful thing.